you built an empire beyond imagining the  pinnacle of human achievement and the  envy of the world did you think it would  last  the Eternal City at Lori's monument to  power culture and learning but the old  wolf life wounded by jackals circled by  vultures worried to death by a thousand  tiny fishes mouse brought globe by your  own ro  these are the death throes of roll the  light of civilization Tim's and got us  and you've such precious time left to  hide your women for your children to cry  even at the moment of your final defeat  you will take no comfort no place  for I uncommon  I ride with a million warriors I bring  the end okay I am the spirit of  and I will watch your world burn  you